i'm not sure if you said it just joking
around but you think you mentioned that
building a youtube channel can
kind of make you go insane why do you
say that
building uh
building a youtube channel
i mean i think in order to
put yourself on camera to have talking
points
to operate the camera to operate the
audio
to field questions to
get rid of you know to block out all of
the bad comments to bring up and
reinforce the good comments
i think you have to be a special kind of
sociopath
truthfully i mean it's a lot of work for
one person to do it's definitely helpful
if you have a wife that's involved or a
family member or a friends or
a group of other youtubers that are like
in the mix with you i i definitely think
that's helpful but for one
person a one-man band to do it it's a
herculean effort
um and it normally means that you're
cutting out
all forms of like social life so
thank god for my wife she lets me just
she's
she believes in it she's trusting it so
she's letting me go you know
full speed at it but you know at the
extent of my own sanity sometimes of not
having a social life and
you know feeling like a little bit of a
prisoner a prisoner of my own success
you know do you think um views and
social media
likes equate with happiness
i think yeah you know that's a slippery
slope
when i first got into this uh
what i wanted the most was to give
people
a sense of shock or wonder in the videos
to leave them with a lasting impression
and i think it's inevitable that you end
up comparing yourselves you end up
comparing yourself to your last videos
and you sort of get sucked into this
game of working for the views and
panhandling for
views and comments it's it's just part
of the mix there's no way to separate it
as much as i try and as much as i want
to i have to like
spend an enormous amount of time kind of
brainwashing myself that like
that is not important even though it has
an enormous
it's it's tough do you think you would
have started
um a few years back if you had known
not just the the pressure of putting out
something that your audience will like
and top the last one but also with your
own expectations
you know you know what's crazy is that
uh yeah i do kind of wish i started
earlier i think it would have been
easier for me i would have had more free
time i would have had a little bit more
energy that kind of thing
but if i look back in the last two years
of just my technical skills they have
ballooned in that short two years of
having the youtube channel
the the amount that i've learned and
packed in there
is exponential to the first two years
that i had
you know so putting yourself under
deadline and putting yourself under
public scrutiny
and putting up bodies of work to be
judged
that is it's a whole process
of of whittling down your skills and and
really really refining your talent and
just
um sharpening that blade so
sure i wish i would have started years
before
but i also think that i would have had
less to offer
and i think that i might not have
put so much into it as i am now maybe
that's something that
when you get older you start doing i
don't know
but do you think you would have um
actually gone for it knowing
how difficult it is and it is very
isolating and people don't realize that
about
the job
i don't think i don't know that i would
i don't i think it's one of those things
where you kind of get sucked in
and and so when people look at the
channel and they look at the amount of
work that i put into certain videos
they're like wow you put so much time
and effort into that but to me that's
like the normal that's just like oh yeah
i'm putting a body work so it takes this
and that and
you just have to you have to invest you
got to do it and so
if i had known that from the start maybe
not maybe i would have said
you know what's an easier way to to make
my art and not have to
worry about rejection every time i
upload something i don't know
you